This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
And in this hour on radio lab, we're talking about the relationship,
sometimes the uneasy relationship between the brain and the body.
Most people who have brains, and that would include,
I think most of the listeners here, uh,
think the relationship between brain and body is more like the relationship of a
commander to a command D, right?
The brain makes the orders and the body response,
but I think the more accurate way is to think of this as a conversation
[inaudible]
between the brain and the body. How do you mean? Well, because any movement,
even a very basic one, let's just say a wagging my tongue, I think.
Okay. Very simple really. But it still involves three steps. First,
the brain has to issue the command
concentration tongue station. This is mission control, commence wagon.
Second, the command must be executed [inaudible] third.
Now this is the crucial step. The tongue. In this case,
we ports back to the brain.
All we have a wagging. I repeat. We have wagons.
Yeah. By completing the loop,
because you can control the foot. Kevin fully, she can control. This is full.
Your Mirror coordinates over to Roger that Michigan.
Now my, this happens, this conversation you're having right now,
oh nine or alpha. It happens constantly all over your body.
Your brain is issuing commands. [inaudible] come and let me.
Parts of your body are receiving the command and reporting back,
right leg standing by and this conversation right arm heads up to something
really quite important. It ends up to incense of yourself.
It's an unconscious sense which really allows you to to move normally.
That's Oliver sacks again,
the neurologist we talked to at the start of the program,
you have of course a sense of smell and if touch and if taste,
he says this sixth sense also has a name is sometimes called proprioception.
Proprioception.
Proprioception is the unconscious sense by which the position of one's limits
the posture of one's body is automatically monitored.
Yeah,
nope. Imagine he says what would happen if all of a sudden this sixth sense,
this conversation that you were always having with your body,
suppose it went away. We all have this in a slight way.
For example,
if you go to the dentist and sometimes half of your mouth or your tongue is
numbed, the tongue may feel very large.
You may grab the Dental Mirror to reassure yourself that all is okay and this
doesn't, it doesn't reassure you do. You can still wag your tone.
Your brain is still sending messages to the top
pump station, turn station. This is mission control. The tongue
haven't, Kung isn't sending messages back anymore.
So you can you anything. You know that feeling? Yeah, yeah, of course. Now,
could you imagine that instead of just losing your tongue,
your tongue not responding, suppose your whole body doesn't respond.
What would that be like? I'm in,
we have words like deaf or we don't have a word for being ineffective.
Deaf and blind to one's own body
and yet there are people who have a condition that rare and that horrible.
No proprioception. We talked to such a person,
Ian Waterman and convinced him and his doctor and very good friend Jonathan Cole
to crowd themselves into a very little recording studio. The other,
the BBC, fantastic in Southampton, in England, Hello America.
And we asked them to talk to us. Oh, you got a sexy voice.
Ah, and you hear us? Can you hear me? You're other. Hi. We can, Oh God, yeah.
Thank you guys for coming and doing this with us. Yeah.
Will you just ask us some questions and we'll answer them as best we can far
away. All right. Well let me just start it then. Now, can you remember,
I'm sure you can.
What happened that led to this total change in your life?
See, so it began with what I thought was, um, uh,
a bout of the flu or a very heavy, heady cold.
And uh,
I was at the shop probably worked and felt tired and lethargic.
The guy that owned the shop said, look, you know, you'd look on, well, go home,
take it easy. I took the day off,
went home and I've always been pretty energetic and I hate being stuck in doors
and might have. And I thought, well, the fresh air will do me some good.
It got to the shed and pulled the motor mower out, pulled the what out with,
what's the, what do you call it, the mower that the lawnmower out of the shed.
It's going to be one of those cultural moments where you guys call it something
else. No, not quite. And pulled the uh,
lawnmower out of the shed and primed it up and started it and it started
chugging away and as I engage the gear off it went and I couldn't keep up with
it.
It was a fairly slowly important as sort of Loma and I just did their bemused
thinking, how come I just can't keep up with them,
Ma and didn't really attend to much more than, you know,
I'm just tired and sluggish and lethargic and,
and went back to my bedroom and laid down and, and,
and did some seriously thing.
And the following morning I went to get up and out of bed and collapsed against
the radio twice. Fell, slipped, fell,
tumbled out of the bed in front against the radiator.
[inaudible].
It's very difficult to do to describe
[inaudible]
as I lay there and I was laying flat,
I had a rippling sensation in my tummy around the ankles,
a a tingling sensation for once we've had a chairman I,
I felt disembodied.
I remember waking up with a hand on my face and not realizing that it was mine.
Simple movement, simple movements. The simplest of movements.
Pick up a cup to eat, to eat biscuits.
Those things are certainly very hard. I couldn't control anything totally.
I mean from the neck down,
I had no control over over my limbs and for the next 12 years he went from
hospital to hospital.
Doctors couldn't help him because he never seen anything quite this drastic
until they finally did meet a doctor, Jonathan Cole,
who began to help him figure out what might be going on.
So let me ask Jonathon for a second. What is wrong with the n
he had at the time he had his illness,
the last class of peripheral nerve cells to do with sensation.
He lost touch, but also his movement and position sense had got,
is this unusual? I mean in your experience or independence who we talked to,
but I normally say that we know of about six in the world really who are like
this.
No one really in the world knew what proprioception did and what the effects of
the loss of proprioception would be until it,
and when they first met, Dr. Cole said to him, he said,
how do you manage? How do you cope with this? Unbelievably,
he was the first doctor to ask that question in told him that on his own over
the 12 years he had figured out how to walk again and how to grasp a cup again
and explained that he did this by carefully breaking down and then reassembling
every single move he made.
Started this.
Um,
I was laying in bed one day in hospital and I wanted to sit up and it just
wouldn't happen. And then laying there in frustration,
I just thought the whole process through and I broke it down into quite simple,
small movements and I lay flat.
I checked where absolutely everything was before I started.
And I then started with the head and folded and tucked my chin onto my chest as
if to start the first part of the cow that I moved my arms slightly forward and
I started to tighten some muscles in my tummy and around my back.
And then I started to curl myself to sit in an upright position.
And when I got there, I was sent down to 400 we fell out of bed.
He has studied movement. You don't wait.
No one in history has ever studied before. No ballet dotes,
no professor of neurology has ever had to study movement the way ear does every
day
because every day, every move that Ian makes,
he has to consciously direct it as though Ian, we're two people,
a puppeteer and a puppet.
His mind is directing and his body is obeying and the strings of Ian's puppet
instantly or his eyes are controlling all my movement with my sight at,
because he doesn't have this feedback information coming from his limbs back to
his brain pro for Septa feedback cause that's missing.
Unless he looks directly at the limb, he wants to move, he can't move it.
If I look
away from from my hand, I lose all connection with it.
Or what happens if, if it's dark or if the lights are out, we know it's,
he can't afford darkness. If the lights go out accidentally,
Gus call it a dangerous place to be posts all over.
He has not turned out the lights in the night, in the last decades.
Wow. To stay in the world in motion. He must focus,
always focus. He's back. He spent a long time just training with paper clips.
I use them now occasionally and I still don't like the little devils. Um,
you know, I mean we wait, when you're, when you're manipulating the paper clip,
what are you actually trying to figure out how to put on the way it isn't,
but he's, uh, I lost my fell off. She could repeat that. Oh,
okay. We should do Jess. Is the headphones back on yet? Hang on. I'll do it.
That's my job by the way. Is He, is he able to put on, I mean is this,
you can tell me what's going on,
but is he able to grab the headphones so he can grab the headphones and put them
on? But because I'm putting the headphones over the top of my head,
I can't see exactly where the headphones are in relation to the rest of me. Um,
although I would finally get this a lot quicker if Jonathan just puts them on
and uh, he likes to feel,
what I was asking was what were you doing with the paperclips?
All that time I was giving paper clips as a, as an exercise to, to,
to get my fingers to move again and to, to,
to threaten them together and then try and clip them. A very,
very frustrating therapy. But one has to admit that it is,
it is a good one.
And so an awful lot of find extras movement to get paperclips together and,
and apart again.
But the idea of breaking down every move you make into sub moves and sub sub
moves and then relearning everything. It's exhausting. Very,
very mentally tiring cause it takes such total concentration.
What if you were walking down the street and suddenly a thought like a daydream
potter? John Jonathan has a very good memory of that and maybe, uh,
that would be good to come from [inaudible] Ian and I were walking through
Oxford having done some groundbreaking experiments or whatever and he had
suddenly stumbled and I'd never seen him stumble ever before.
And he was looking at a pretty girl.
These thoughts had drifted from walking and from the concrete ahead of him to
what he'd liked to do to this girl while she, she was a about 18,
she had not brown hair,
lovely legs and miniskirt and it was a navy blue dress with white polka dots as
a family program, but walks anyway,
he has to think about walking the floor merely the around the erotic sort of
charge cost you your ability to be that sort of charged but any distraction
really. Um, took me away from my focus,
which is where is my left foot in relation to my rights for tomorrow and my
balance at the moment and how am I actually going through this process?
At what stage am I in this movement and to suddenly be distracted by that by a
wast of perfume minute pretty girl took all that concentration away.
It can be taken away by the song of a bird or all the sound of music drifting
from somewhere. Just on that day, it was a pretty girl
today. If you saw Ian on the street,
you wouldn't be able to tell that he has this handicap.
He has figured out how to live a very deliberate and in a way kind of a normal
life. He drives a car, he works, he drives that car.
Yeah. My, my latest car, which is a very nice Mercedes. Um,
I do drive the same speed as everybody else and all the rest. Oh, Costa, you,
I can react as quickly as anybody else.
It's an automatic car and it has hand controls.
It's the only favor to my disability really. But, um,
I tend to do with my drive and what I do within the way that I managed my life,
which is I plan ahead.
I'm just wondering about my, my, my last question really for free,
and I guess this is a, have you solved this problem as best you can? I mean,
do you feel like you're one person or do you feel,
uh, cut in half like a mind directing a body? Like, like maybe two people?
Oh, I don't think about it in the way that you've just, just related that,
um, I just think about, I want to get up,
I want a cup of tea and this is the process I have to apply to do that. Yeah.
That's what, that's what we all do.
I didn't see stories like this involve heroes.
They involve people who try their best under certain circumstances and then
tested it a way that many of us had not we could look for that
you'll tell to hand and you play it as you.
This Chiu Chan
[inaudible] stop off.
Thanks to Ian Waterman and to neurologist Jonathan Cole.
Dr. Cole wrote a very nice,
lovely book about Ian called pride and a daily marathon.
He spoke to us together from the BBC studios in Southampton.
It was from those from,
Gosh, I really should read the book. Human man. Look up. Look at the chair,
the chair. Be Fun. Lunch.
Cultish room doesn't get it. That's it. It's a dog.